la policía pone una orden de cierre en
esta mezquita de pantano suburbio al
noreste de parís
el templo cerrará por seis meses bajo
acusaciones de incitación al odio y de
haber jugado un rol en el crimen de
samuel para ti la mezquita difundió un
vídeo en facebook días antes de su
asesinato denunciando al profesor de
historia por mostrar caricaturas del
profeta mahoma durante una clase de
libertad de expresión
varios de 2.300 fieles de la mezquita
expresaron su rechazo a la decisión es
triste es una vergüenza para toda la
comunidad para la ciudad para todos los
musulmanes nosotros los fieles de esta
mezquita porque estamos pagando por el
error de una persona las autoridades
creen que la mezquita tiene lazos
cercanos con el salafismo y que su líder
eva mendez knicks es conocido por sus
posturas radicales
el administrador de la mezquita niega
esas acusaciones
no conocemos a ningún salafista aquí
quienes son los salafistas no lo sabemos
conocemos a los fieles hay mucha gente
que viene que a veces no conocemos a las
personas a veces sólo con él es la
personalidad del imán y la difusión de
un vídeo en internet para este profesor
de derecho
no son motivos suficientes para el
cierre permanente de la mejilla
si el vídeo es el único elemento será
difícil cerrar la mezquita por otro lado
durante los allanamientos policiales se
pueden encontrar por ejemplo materiales
o documentos que ilustren la
radicalización la incitación al odio la
incitación a cometer ataques a la
mezquita tiene dos meses para apelar
esta decisión en un tribunal
administrativo